et
les malgaches comme symbole de cette
fête de l'indépendance le département et
la région se sont associés pour célébrer
en compagnie de la communauté malgache
la 56e fête de l'indépendance l'occasion
pour les collectivités de rappeler
l'importance de la coopération avec
madagascar et des projets communs dans
une perspective de développement de la
zone océan indien
nous avons souhaité avec rega simonard
président du département et et moi-même
avec l'ensemble des élus donc avoir un
moment réservé particulier pour
l'ensemble des personnalités des
personnes la communauté malgache
notamment les associations et tous ceux
qui oeuvrent finalement à renforcer les
liens de coopération entre la réunion et
madagascar vaut qu'à l'occasion du 56e
anniversaire de l'indépendance de la
grande île
donc c'est effectivement le moment pour
nous de pouvoir avoir un moment festif
un moment de retrouvailles entre entre
les réunionnais et tous ceux qui ont
participé à construire et la réunion et
notamment madagascar
la fête organisée par département et par
la reynard et régions mcginn évidemment
ce lien entre la réunion et madagascar
anniversaire marque bien des liens forme
et surtour au delà de la fête
s'ils sortent furieusement sur le fait
que ça doit être à nouveau une prise de
conscience pour dire que au delà du
gadget politique bel air forcé
de l'élégance politique l'on n'a
l'obligation d'être ensemble et donner
du sens au sénat lundi au sénat c'est à
dire les réunionnais on est français on
les repère on a pensé une zone 1 après
nadio ceni vena destin en commun
si provence malgache composée de
dix-huit tribus ont été présentés à
l'occasion de cette journée
une manière de montrer la richesse
culturelle de cet immense territoire
coiffure habillement dialecte une
diversité qui composent la nation
malgache des artisans étaient également
présents pour montrer la richesse
artisanale de la grande île astrologie
gyroscope malgache pierre spécialités
culinaires autant de savoir-faire à
valoriser auprès des réunionnais il ya
aussi la la richesse de la richesse
culinaire malgache et ont fait qu'on
aime les ont fait connaître ceux des
petits tas tôt que vous avez vu je pense
bien on a fait
dégustation pour les gens il ya quand
même des artisans qui montrent leur
savoir faire
il ya aussi un groupe folklorique
keep vraiment qu'est venue de madagascar
les invités ont pu découvrir le marché
malgache et ses nombreux exposants une
journée placée sous le signe du partage
de la solidarité est aussi l'occasion de
faire la fête avec toutes les
associations malgaches qui oeuvre à la
promotion de la culture de leur pays